I just came out of the gender parity
group and we had a fabulous discussion
made several commitments and I know our
organization Ernst & Young is very
committed to continuing to promote the
business case for the inclusiveness of
women and people of different
ethnicities sexual orientation but
purpose of all of that is to have a
diverse set of perspectives around the
table frankly at this point in time with
financial crisis if you have and you
actually have a diverse organization
which we do and you in power the use of
that diversity to tackle issues tackle
challenges to create innovative ways to
address the challenges that we face we
think we'll get better answers that was
one of the recommendations coming out of
the gender parity group we're committed
to it I know the other members of the
gender parity group are so I'm delighted
I just hope we get more organizations
truly embracing the value of diversity
inclusiveness and how it can produce
tangibly different outcomes for the
future